what's going on everyone uh last night i
was
speaking uh i was one of the speakers
and clubhouse it's a new app
uh you can follow me there it's at
hormozy um but anyways
i i was i was one of the speakers of
this app and
they were asking questions like if you
had to start all over you know what
would you do
what's the biggest mistakes you've made
and things like that and
one of the things that came up in my
mind is one of the hardest things about
being an entrepreneur
which is the disconnect between
the right decision and the right outcome
and so let me explain
so you've you if you've listened to my
stuff i talk about repeating successful
actions right find something that works
and keep doing it over and over again
right
but the thing is is your decision-making
process is ultimately the most valuable
thing
valuable thing that you have right it's
what makes you it's your picker right it
makes you decide
what what way to go who you're going to
marry what business opportunity you're
going to pursue
how you're going to price how you're
going to start marketing what you're
going to learn first who you're going to
you know get mentoring from all of these
things so you're going to become friends
with like all of these are decisions
right
and you know you can take the money away
from a billionaire and then they can
recreate it again elon musk you know
lost it and then
gained it all back right and so like the
thing is is the decision making
is what ultimately fuels all these
things and the hardest part
about entrepreneurship and really i mean
i think almost life in general is that
you can make the right decision
and have the wrong outcome and i think
and let me give you a couple examples of
this so
for example um you may say you know what
like i look i listen to warren buffett i
think he's a good investor
and so he says i wouldn't i wouldn't
touch bitcoin right
and i hear that i'm like man well he
knows a little bit more about it than i
do
but his argument was simple it is
speculative which means
i'm buying it not because it has
intrinsic value but only because i
believe that someone else will buy it
for more later
right that's all it is he only believes
in investing in things that have
intrinsic value
and also produce right so they actually
have production
so like a business you buy you still own
the business at the end and then it
spits out production which would be
profit or
crops or whatever right so that's the
basic difference
right and so the thing is is that
you can make the right decision so for
example i chose not to buy bitcoin
two years ago or whatever and now the
amount of money that it would have been
worth is a lot more
was the decision wrong or was it that
the outcome
did not match the quality of the
decision and so let me explain let me
like
unpack this if you are going to change
the way you make decisions because a
decision that you made in the past
that was probably a good decision ended
up bad
you have to apply the same decision
making context or framework
to everything else all right so let me
explain so
if i say i'm now going to
be a speculator right i'm going to be
someone who buys things with the hopes
of selling them later for more
even though the thing itself doesn't
have more value right
if i choose to start making those types
of decisions then
i have to think about all the other
investments i would have made and lost
money on
as a result of that decision making
framework and the place that i heard
this
first was ray dalio in principles so
he's one of the richest men in the world
uh an investor as well he said one of
the hardest things is
passing up on an opportunity and then
seeing it you know
do really really well right he's like
and but the thing is is
i have to think to myself if i were to
use the decision-making framework that
would have made that deal a winner
then i'd have to apply that same
framework to all of these other
businesses or situations that would have
been losers
and my net net of having that different
decision making framework
would ultimately cause me to lose and so
this has been one of the most powerful
concepts for me as an entrepreneur
because what it does is it allows me to
separate the outcome from the quality of
the decision why was it that i did these
things
right and i i can't even tell you like
so for example
you know actually i won't even give that
one but like their their decisions that
i made when i was younger
that ended up being you know poor later
but when i thought back about why i made
the decision
i would make the same decision today so
it's not fair for me to say
well i wouldn't have made the same call
now but you can't use the information
that you have today
to make the decision that you would have
made in the past because then it means
that you're a different person because
you're not using information that you
have access to
right and so claiming that the this
decision that i did in the past that
didn't end up well
you know working out in my favor was the
wrong call
can just be really poisonous and it may
not be true now if you make a mistake
because you had
poor calculations and you repeat the
same mistake over and over again
then you should consider looking at your
decision-making calculus and see if you
need to tweak some things right
but for me this has been one of the
hardest learned lessons and emotionally
one of the most trying
is looking at decisions i've made
looking at the outcome and being able to
separate
was this a good decision independent of
the outcome and i'll wrap this up with
just a quick example to show you
if you had a perfect baseball swing
right you're just an amazing you know
batter
right if someone gets up there and
they're the best batter in the world and
you strike out
is it because their swing is horrible is
it because they they don't have the
right decision making
about how they swing at pitches or how
they pick the pitches
probably not he's probably really good
batter right because i just said he's
the best
but it still means he's going to strike
out and it still means he's going to
he's gonna get out and hit pop flies and
all that kind of stuff
but he's gonna be an amazing batter with
three
you know 350 average or whatever and
still two out of three times he's gonna
strike out or
basically you know not get on base get
out and so when i think about that
like you can be the best at this thing
and still only be right a certain
percentage of the time
right and so rather than that batter
striking out once and saying i need to
change my swing
and then getting back up there and
striking out again and be like i need to
change my swing
and always resetting the baseline
instead being like
i understand that if i apply this swing
to enough at bats quite literally
i will get the opportunity to knock it
out of the park and me knocking out of
the park on
one of these right decisions will
ultimately outweigh
the negatives of the wrongs that i have
done right
um and so for me obviously with in the
context of your own life like
i talk about decision making in other
videos but you want to make sure that
you never bet the farm and you don't
put everything on black when you cannot
afford to lose right like
don't bet everything but i mean
sometimes
you know things get crazy but for the
most part don't bet everything
the point being just like a big ball
player you're going to have these
decisions that you have to make
and not changing your decision calculus
your decision maker your picker
every single time is going to ultimately
allow you to judge the quality of your
decisions based on these principles
and so that is one of the hardest things
that i've had to learn and i hope that
the illustration with baseball made
sense to you
if it did drop a comment otherwise
keeping awesome i'll catch you guys next
vid
bye